Ladies and gentlemen, grab a Kleenex, grab something to cry.
It's going to be a very sad episode today. Very serious with you guys.
It's going to be about the art of how people retire on YouTube.
How marketers retire. Very depressing.
Please make sure you're somewhere where you can openly cry because compared,
compared to this, the notebook was a comedy.
It's actually why he came in the studio at night.
I didn't want to make anyone sad during their office stay right.
You don't want to cry in front of your coworker. Introducing first,
our first contestant, Kevin David.
So for all of those reasons, I'm quitting YouTube.
It isn't true. Kevin, after all we've been through together,
you would meet don't quit. Now, what am I going to do with myself?
How am I going to make YouTube videos of you've quit? Oh,
I quit social media for 48 hours.
Or we do actually get into all of those.
I do want to take just a few quick seconds and address my last video about
quitting YouTube because wow,
hands of thousands of views in the first couple of hours.
When you retire, the view counter goes to marketers,
are this really weird species of human? Where nothing means what it says.
They mean, I mean, take Billy. Gene is marketing. He didn't only quit YouTube.
He said, he's retiring for good.
What's up. It's Billy. And I know you're busy, so I'll be quick.
I sent this to you in your email. Um,
but if you didn't have a chance to read it yet, I wanted to let you know that,
uh, I am retiring. Uh, so what I did, um,
as I took everything I've ever created, and I'm just pretty much giving it away.
Giving it away, which is code that's marketer,
speak for selling it for $69. That's right. Giving it away.
I'm practically giving it away guys for $69.
And actually we learned two weeks into his long retirement. I mean,
this is a man who needs to rest from all his hard labor teaching everyone how to
market effectively. He decided to drop another video. He came out of retirement.
How to create a giveaway that gets a ton of engagement.
How do you turn a giveaway into actual sales? Oh boy,
I feel like I already know the answer to this.
Simple and easy way to do it. You can do it today.
Cause there's one thing Garney interests with people who want stuff for free,
pretty much giving it away.
But how do you actually translate that into money in your pocket?
Step one, retire. Step two, charge $69 for your giveaway.
Now guys, the first two, I mean, I know I was joking, but this one,
this one we're at really well, bring it to your, to your eyes,
ladies and gentlemen, can we get a sad, uh, some sad music going,
please come on. Let's play. I'll just start playing.
Some sad music.
Um, you know, this is a very sad moment. We have one of the greatest YouTubers,
Jagger nuggets, retiring guys. Things will never be the same.
You usually don't
get a close up. Nick.
Why did he say get a closeup? Like as if he's going to say something important,
but then it's just of him drinking water. Why not take that out?
Is it to make it more sad?
I have a picture of you pathetically drinking water from a chalice.
Oh, something like close your neck closer.
Get closer, Nick.
I really want to emphasize guys. This is not a series.
This is not a clickbait video.
I will be officially quitting YouTube as of January 1st, 2020,
January 1st, 2020.
This is the last video I'll ever make on YouTube. It doesn't feel real.
It really doesn't.
It's scary for me to think that this is the last video I will ensure this works,
but I always suck at saying that story fire doesn't CC'd I will
die by the fire. Wait, what?
No, there's no need to do that. Uh, Jagger nuggets. That is my guarantee to you.
Wow.
No.
No guarantees necessary. You don't have.
To do I make a decision. I own it. And I commit.
And you guys heard it here. I mean, we can't talk them out of it.
Barbara.
I'm willing to do the hard things and let go of things that have been in my life
forever.
It's like when somebody passes away or you lose somebody
and you can't get them back so much, you want to say,
or if only I did this or I'll never be enough and I'm sure
years from now, I'll be like, Oh, I wish I,
I wish they knew how much they meant to me. I really hope I articulated that.
Wow.
I didn't actually believe it was a farewell video at first.
I thought it was another one of these clickbait liars who would come back to the
platform within weeks. Maybe even days, but not you McJagger nuggets.
When you say something, you stick by it.
I'm going to close this off for the last time forever. All right.
Jeez. Oh. Be able to death
and don't forget to keep it rigid.
Keep it rigid. Who, who approved that?
If you're all off about getting demonetized? I think I have the solution.
I have the crystal ball. If you don't tell your face.
To keep it rigid, it stay lit. Okay.
Now you're just playing with me. That's all my fault. That's my fault.
I was taking this seriously. You're close at your final words. You know what?
When you were saying, I want to say the right word.
So much. You want to say the eulogy? It's like when somebody passes away.
I don't know what to say. I thought to myself, you don't need the right words,
but I take that back there. Aren't right words. But there are wrong words.
Keep it rigid. By the way, I know this looks like I'm being mean to him.
Just wait 20 seconds. Okay. Don't get mad at me for 20 seconds.
Everything will make sense.
Check your full life.
I have returned one month.
I'm wondering why you channel back please. I don't have any money.
I need my journal back. Uh, Joe, it's you guys.
I think we should have a sit down conversation.
Kind of like how I left this whole thing. I will die by the fire.
We got a lot to talk about. That is my guarantee to you.
I should've never been so negative towards YouTube and like, to be fair.
I still don't agree with a lot of the things that they've done,
especially to me personally,
with demonetization and all those things I talked about before,
but I don't want to get into that. Um,
I still don't agree with a lot of things still being part of sport, but, um,
I really just wanted to help people.
That's what's brought me back more than anything I [inaudible].
Is it really? Is it.
You weren't too lit over there. You weren't as rigid as you remember.
I want to see how you guys are doing. I want to make sure you guys are okay.
I know a lot of my audience didn't follow me over to story fire and that sucks.
This is painful guys. This is the life of a retiree YouTuber.
They always say I'm retiring. I'm going to do that.
Literally means I have a marketing gimmick, a stunt plan.
This is a gigantic stunt.
They're not actually being genuine or that's what I did think until I saw this.
What's up guys. Thank you so much for hitting this page.
As you saw from the other video,
I'm taking a break and I'm retiring with a very heavy heart.
Ladies and gentlemen, I don't mean to Pat myself on the back,
but it takes a big man to admit when he was wrong and wow. Was I wrong?
This is Maxim Trubisky.
I used to think all marketers were the same till I saw max icy.
A man of class of honor. Someone who wouldn't lie to us.
This is a man. Look at this poor guy. He's in a cast to cast double cast.
It's Christmas. He's laying in bed,
but he won't let that stop him from helping humanity.
After talking with doctors for weeks, talking with my family,
flying over them out here to Los Angeles,
I have decided I will focus entirely on my recovery from the skiing accident.
You focus max, you do whatever you have to do, buddy. I feel bad, honestly,
for accusing these YouTubers of faking retirement, that is not right.
You know, you take all the time. You need, you've done so much for the world.
Uh, so why are you making this video? Anyway, every.
Single Shopify e-comm brand we built and didn't run
that we were gonna run in 2021 and the end of 2020 for the holiday
season, because we have about 20 brands that we built, which are.
This is a sales pitch. It's just to set this man broke his arms.
Literally this man has to use it to sell you something. He cannot.
He's like Billy Jean. He can't even go away and leave us alone. And he's like,
I got to sell, Hey, I got some for you and it's going to cost you.
But unfortunately I will not be able to focus on these new brands.
So these 20 brands that are already done, right?
We feel we've built them before. They're already finished.
We're going to run them ourselves.
So then just run them yourself. I don't understand don't you have a team.
I can't, you run them yourself.
And instead of one of you guys, if you're watching this video,
now you can get access to a fully built business, a fully done brand.
Oh, he's just such a nice guy.
How much is he selling this for $20 and look only two stores remaining.
Oh my gosh.
Only two stores remaining ladies and gentlemen terrified,
but wait a second.
What's this there's another video on his Vimeo account that was left public.
Oops. Oh no. Max video nine Christmas.
What's this. He says that he was only selling this to 20 people, right?
He only had 20 stores.
What's up guys.
Thank you so much for being one of the 20 students that now have your hands on a
brand new business.
But oops, Whoa, wait, wait, wait. How many views does this video have?
The only people who would have been watching this are people who bought the
course, right? So it's 20 views, right? Or 21 views. Cause I'm here to,
Oh, what's this 455.
Does that mean 455 people purchased 20 stores.
You're you're telling me that there weren't only 20 stores.
That would have to be that. Oh my gosh. Shannon, Claus. Isn't real.
And there aren't only two stores remaining. Oh, no way, dude.
I don't believe it. I can't believe it guys. That that's impossible. Next.
You're going to tell me that the tooth fairy isn't real. No way, dude. No way.
I don't believe it, dude.
I think this is honestly my favorite one because he's monetizing his own injury
and lying about what his intentions are. I'm retiring, I'm retiring,
you're leaving for two months, selling all the way,
getting your team's calls all the way.
And you're probably not even leaving for two months.
I'm just going to say this right now.
Anytime at YouTube makes a big deal about retiring and Oh my gosh guys,
I'm sorry. I'm going to leave 90% chance. It's fake.
I mean, I hate to be the bearer of bad news and everything.
I hate to be that guy right? To tell you this,
to spoil things for you, the magic of YouTube, but it's true.
These people, uh,
they used to use retirement for clickbait and profit and I love to see it guys.
Let me know who your favorite was of our little series here.
And I think if we can agree on anything,
it's that marketers are a different breed of human.
They're just another level anyways. That's it for now? See you next time.
[Inaudible].